Hey Youtubers happy 2017, so starting the
year off right Ben Affleck, just trolling
the fandom a little bit about the Batman movie.
So I'm going to explain what's going on.
He talked about maybe they're not gonna do
it.
So I included one of the most epic of Ben
Affleck rants in this.
It'll make you so excited about the Batman
movie.
There is a new round of the flash ring giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and just leave a Batman related comment on
this video be sure to click that bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything.
So what's going on is Ben Affleck really trolling
fans?
Maybe I won't do the Batman movie, there's not a script, if it's not great were not going
to do anything.
So the just so much stuff going on that makes
me believe that this is not completely true
Rob Liefeld actually had like a hot take were he's
like that's called leverage because Ben Affleck
is writing the script with Geoff John's.
Of course, and he's directing.
Meaning that as the actor who is doing all
these other things, to he effectively has
almost complete creative control over the
Batman movie which as a creator is what you
want, but the thing is is that Batman is the
biggest franchise that Warner Bros. has had
in the last 20 to 30 years like it's literally
the biggest money earner they've ever had
next to Harry Potter and the J.R.R.
Tolkien movies like the hobbit and the Lord
of the rings.
So they're not can it take that and let anybody
do whatever they want to with it no matter
how awesome they are and how big they been
blowing it up in Hollywood because when you
think of Ben Affleck like a bunch of different
pictures come into your mind like you think
of Kevin Smith era Ben Affleck you think
of daredevil Jennifer Garner era Ben Affleck
and then you think of like director era Ben Affleck that brought him to today like
the person who wins Oscars for directing movies,
but what's the actual quote that everybody's
been circulating and freaking out about, so
there was a big profile on him for his other
movies like he's doing live by night that's
being released in a couple weeks we'll talk
about that in the second because it's the
next big candidate next to the Super Bowl
for the new Justice league trailer.
So that's a completely separate thing, but they're doing this big profile on Ben Affleck.
You know how much his life has changed.
Now that he's been directing all these award-winning
movies and he's taken on the persona of the
Batman.
So when they asked him about the Batman movie
that he is making.
He says well that's the idea, but it's not
a set thing, and there's no script, which
makes you freak out a little bit, but then
goes on to say if it doesn't come together
in a way I think is really great.
I'm not going to do it.
So I think were all in agreement when we say
that Affleck is definitely going to do the
Batman movie it's just that they're trying to
avoid repeating the past.
So they want to wait for the right script
with the right creative before they actually
start rolling cameras and start scheduling
stuff like scheduling a release date.
Even though they kind of push the second Justice
league a little bit further out than it was
supposed to drop to make room for the Batman
movie.
The just like hoping that it all comes together
and it drops during 2018.
So when Ben Affleck says that they don't have
a script yet really what I think he's saying
is that they don't have a finished script
they been working on the Batman movie.
Like Geoff John's was almost radio silent
for all of last year but he has a whole bunch
of other stuff on his plate, in addition to
the Batman movie.
So like at the beginning of this year like
Geoff John's just went on this complete rant
were he's like I'm so excited about all the
stuff that's coming like it was it was wonderful
because he's been so quiet for so long but
he was talking about the wonder woman movie,
just because that's the next big DC movie.
He was involved in that but it's sort of like
tail end.
Zack Snyder, so I think the Zack Snyder's
wife was still a producer on the film.
So it's sort of like the beginning of Geoff
John's era, but is not like 100%.
Geoff John's creative and then they been editing
the Justice league film and getting Aqua man
off the ground.
So now the Geoff John's is like one of the
new gods of DC films inside Warner Bros. he
just has like so many other projects to take
care of.
So he had to stop writing comics for little
while, which is a huge bummer which is done
now because he said I will be writing comics
again like tweeted this watchmen picture.
So it's like okay Geoff John's really get
to do some big watchmen comic as part of the
new DC rebirth arc.
So really excited about that.
But then he talked about the new DC TV show
that I did a video about yesterday.
And even though he was kind of quiet about
theres also the Batman movie.
But just because that so far off there still
a lot about the movie and the characters they
put in it, the story they go with, that could
change that they just want to talk too much
about it and then have it all be different
when it actually gets here.
So while it is really funny to hear.
Ben Affleck sort of like mess with people
a little bit and this is actually with the Guardian
that he's talking to the wall it is kind of
funny to hear Ben Affleck say that he might
not do the Batman movie really I think that
just like a little bit of him hedging his
bets and his sense of humor because like if
you talk to Kevin Smith.
He tells the best Ben Affleck stories like
I said there's like three different eras of
Ben Affleck depending on your talking to theirs
like the Kevin Smith young Ben Affleck who
he says was just like crazy fun to hang out
with.
That's from like the 90s all the way up to
the early 2000.
Then he starts to hit it big Kevin Smith tells
this funny story about how he would just go
off just open his mouth and get in so much
trouble going on rants they would sometimes
get him in trouble and cost him movie projects
really good example of that is him going off
on deflate gate which isn't a Hollywood issue,
but you have to imagine him being like this
as a young person in Hollywood all the time
about Hollywood stuff, so this is just hilarious
watch this just like it is the ultimate bull
shits talking outrage of sports ever.
It's so stupid that I can't believe
you may not even realize that they gave him a suspension
for 1/4 of the regular season which is the
equivalent of suspending baseball player for
40 days,
which is what they do when you get busted
taking steroids, which and by the way
if the nfl had a real testing, really knew how to test
for steroids, HGH, in the nfl, there'd be no fucking NFL, so instead what they
they did was to suspend tom brady for four
days for not giving them his cell
phone that's and for having a friend who called
himself the deflator if I got in trouble for
all the things that my friends call themselves
I would be finished okay you want to give
a guy because he doesn't give you his cell
phone as a punishment.
I would never give the organization as leak
prone as the NFL my cell phone so you
can just look through my emails and listen
to my voicemail, especially the NFL that that
that leaks everything, that's right so first they're going to do is leak this shit and I don't know maybe
it's of funny lovely sex messages from
his wife.
Maybe it's just friendly messages from his wife.
Maybe Tom Brady is
So classy and such a fucking gentleman
that he doesn't want people to know that he
may have reflected on his real opinion of
some of his coworkers like guys he plays with
guys it was against his real feelings.
I wouldn't want guys who I didn't think were very
good to know I did think they're very good.
I wouldn't want guys who I thought were
great to know I thought they were great I
want to keep my opinions to myself.
Surely his opinions about professional football are
contained in his emails and texts and his
telephone, not giving your telephone they're
not the FBI, you're not required to. this federal
subpoena you're not required to turn over
your bank records. This is a
conspiracy of people working inside the
NFL who all come from organizations of Tom
Brady whipped their ass over the last 10
to 15 years, so those guys work for the
jets and the Broncos and everybody else who are now
going like "get him hang him".
You know because they have some
slight slimsy pretense and Tom
is so classy
It's a ridiculous smear campaign.
So I would've included more that it was just
so epic, but because is about football.
Not about in a DC comic book Batman related
stuff you just you get the idea.
Don't you wish that actors felt free enough
to speak their mind in that way without fear
of reprisal from big studios pulling projects
out from under them.
It just like the best thing ever.
This is your glorious F bombs dropping Batman
that you been waiting for this whole time.
So we got a publicist and Kevin Smith kind
of jokes that the publicist told him to start
shutting his mouth.
So you have like the Shealy era Ben Affleck
after that his career sort of craters and
then he has the Renaissance when he sort of
reinvents himself as a director in like the
other big thing that happened right before
that is that he met Jennifer Garner so you
sort of have like the director eraBen Affleck
and the Jennifer Garner era Ben Affleck around
the same time that was around 2005 2007 because
gone baby gone was like his first big movie
to direct, so that sort of like the beginning
of the Ben Affleck that you're seeing today
like the more creative visionary au tour version
of Ben Affleck.
So I'm really interested to see what his
Batman movie is like most people just look
at Ben Affleck and they see daredevil or they
see like the Kevin Smith era Ben Affleck,
but he's really completely different like
Kevin Smith talks a lot about him like he
it's really sad because they don't hang out
anymore he's like yeah I haven't really hung out with
Ben Affleck in the last 10 years or so since
he started going out with Jennifer Garner
he attributes that to Jennifer Garner just
absolutely hating him because the way that
he used to talk with Ben Affleck like they
used to make fun of each other like friends
do.
But she took a little personally, so they
had a big falling out and that was the end
of Kevin Smith hanging out with Ben Affleck
it's really fun to see Kevin Smith doing all
the DC TV stuff now.
So this is sort of like his second wind in
superhero land, but is kind of funny to see
him wistfully remember his time hanging out
with the person who is now the biggest star
on the planet playing Batman, so given the
way Kevin Smith talks about Ben Affleck behind
the scenes like the real Ben Affleck the one
that you don't see in front of all the cameras
he's just messing with people little bit everything
is going to be fine with the Batman movie.
He just trolling just a little bit having
a little bit of fun.
So at the end of the day they're just trying
to avoid running into like a Batman returns
to Batman forever and Batman and Robin trajectory
like they don't want this all go down the
toilet that have to wait like another 10 years
for another Christopher Nolan to come along
and just for those that are asking Christopher
Nolan hasn't been involved creatively with
any of the DC stuff that they've done since
the man of steel movie came out.
That was his last time consulting on a DC
project and he wasn't even that involved with
that movie like he had a producer credit on
it and I think that they brought him in, just
because his time on Batman had been so influential
on the way people thought of superheroes like
it was such a real take on the Batman and
they wanted to do that same thing for Superman
even though I think that was kind of a mistake
like man of steel was a fun movie but it wasn't
quite as fun as it could have but you have
to remember that a lot of the producers like
the people in creative control over the movies
have largely been shuffled out of Warner Bros.
and people like Geoff John's have been brought
in to one of the biggest things they did during
2016, which is now making me really excited
for 2017 is change the creative energy behind
the scenes like the people pulling the strings
are now the right people pulling the strings.
So worst case scenario, when they say you
know if the script doesn't come together were
not can it do a Batman movie is just gonna
take a little bit longer to get here which
I'm totally fine with like it's okay if they
push the Batman movie even like another year,
just because they can't crack the script.
There are so many superhero comic book Star
Wars movies coming in the next two years that
if one of them doesn't come you won't notice
like there's literally more movies than most
kids have money to pay to go see.
So do not breakout but let me know like what
you guys think about Ben Affleck just messing
with people behind the scene just like hey
you know, maybe I won't do a Batman movie
like we all totally think that he's going
to do the Batman movie.
There's no way that he's not going to do it
eventually.
It just might not happen right away but for
those you asking about the Justice league
trailer.
So I actually didn't realize that they bumped
his live by night movie.
So because that's coming out within two weeks
of the Super Bowl.
I would not be surprised if that's when the
Justice league trailer comes because originally
his movie was going to be a Christmas movie.
So i'm like okay that's probably when the
gonna drops a new Justice league footage and
then they'll do something else when the Super
Bowl happens, but because they pushed it it's
all coming out around the same time so that
just seems like the next best place for it
to drop.
But when they do drop it.
It's gonna look a lot more polished than the
stuff that they dropped
So far like even the comic con footage that
they dropped earlier was just work print the behind-the-scenes
video which is green screen.
It was literally just somebody filming them
walking around on the sets, it was like actual
finish footage.
So it is gonna be an awesome 2017.
and this is just talking about the DC stuff
this has nothing to do with all the big Marvel
stuff and Star Wars episode eight.
You have to remember there's all that other
stuff is dropping this year. So what I'm going
to do later today is post a video for like
all the big stuff that's coming just in the
next couple of months.
Like for instance Legion is a brand-new X-Men
TV show this dropping on FX.
So most people might not be aware of some
of the stuff that's coming. There's a couple really
cool things that drop during Christmas like
troll hunters that you may not have seen so I'm just
going to do a video for that next later tonight
so look out for that I will say congratulations
to the latest flash ring giveaway winner Sean
J. Please private message me on the back end of
my channel so I can get your contact details.
There was a new round that started in this
video I'll just announce the winner the next time
I post a DC video.
While you guys wait for that to post you can
click here to learn all about that new
DC TV shows coming this year and you can click
here to rewatch that Justice league footage,
thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight!